oh I like this arrangement now well
let's see what happens gotta escape the
pit somehow ninja training welcome to
ninja training
don't touch that play ah what am i legs
doing there oh alright let's try this
once again this time trying to survive
well those nothing I could do
differently at least my torso made it
nine point nine nine nine nine nine drop
my kid here hey kitty I'm free finally I
don't have to pay okay this one's kinda
deadly moon Pogo but there's only one
way to find out wait please
note that it wrong this is the worst
chucky cheese I've ever been to
Oh at least my heart landed where it
deserved in the balls okay so this is
some bad ninja guy oh I didn't get a
scratched haha
I only have a leg through my nards but
that hardly matters oh whoa you're a
self-destruction technique tonight oh I
didn't fake out all right nope you
missed you impaled yourself on my oh you
only took my arms now how will I army
don't expose your ass to the Poon's
99.9% in past it was impossible to get
over that barrier there wow wow I guess
I didn't need feet after all this one is
called hello ready to suffer I think
maybe whoa where did I go what's going
on all right then oh wow oh my balls oh
my face oh let me through let me through
please
oh God
Oh God come on once more with fever
oh my donut throw alright wait did I
warn hey that would have won the throne
which means we need to maximum don't get
it in the death come on baby that's good
I oh how the death has been blocked
thank goodness
wait no hang on wait wait are you
literally climbing into the death you
dick alright kiddies don't lose your
heads this time one more day please
there's so much Sun and happiness to be
had the death you damned dick you pieces
stop the tentaclear boss battle number
two I don't know what that means
but hopefully it will be okay come here
you boss [ __ ] I'm gonna get you I'm
sure I'm oh I'm almost oh god I blame
the lag
Wow the hardest obstacle course how hard
can it do wrong ball throw whoop oh no
god damn it come on anything but that
climb climb wise is oh wow I didn't
climb I died
lime boil over all the problems with
this one ah you missed me now you [ __ ]
now you suffer consequences yes yes you
suffer many consequences as I entered
the winner's circle good not care if you
have impaled my penis onto the wall it
don't matter
I just do dance but the dance for great
home country the city of Terror how much
they out of control
oh god that was so awesome
look at this Oh Jo ho Oh God
well I've turned into a double unicorn
and that's all that matters
these are all those rooms I recognize
those prunes anywhere oh uh I seem to
have entered the valley of the shadow of
death but they seem to have accepted me
as one of their own so easy couldn't
possibly lose this level it's so easy
over lll
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow leave a like
add it to your favorites or share with
your friends on Facebook and Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video